this episode of the minimalists is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
non-minimalists
hello minimizers welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists what is the sound of
simplicity um is it the gentle ocean
waves brushing against a pristine beach
[Laughter]
[Music]
is it an echo in your home after
removing all the excess stuff
or maybe it's a sweeping musical
soundtrack that reinforces and amplifies
a mood
today
we have one of our favorite musicians on
the podcast yeah to talk about
the sound of simplicity andrew bell is
here ladies and gentlemen let's give him
a round of applause
thank you thanks so much for being here
man oh my gosh absolute pleasure this is
like a dream come true
what other what other podcasts do you
know that have a studio audience very
very few especially these days
it's a rather minimal yeah studio
audience you know what's fascinating
ryan and i have radically different
musical tastes okay
but we agree on one thing
andrew bell is our favorite musician
yeah no way absolutely man come on 100
100
i'm telling you man that matt carney uh
concert that you did like that was
i mean that yeah that was one of my that
is probably my favorite concert i've
ever attended man it was absolutely
black bear yeah dude
that's like the best album of the last
decade
i totally agree with that oh man i hope
i can live up to all this well so
andrew had this album his second album
came out in uh 2013
and ryan and i the very next year we
went on the road we did 100 cities 119
events everywhere we're just driving
around his toyota corolla 10 months
straight sleeping on people's couches
and floors and occasionally if we sold
enough books in one night we'd stay in
like a hampton inn
really live it up you know la quinta yes
yeah there are quite a few la cuentos
bed bugs
well and then i tell you it's the one
album like we played all year and it
never got worn out and it's still
i still can listen to that thing like
start to finish and like yeah my wife
and i listen to it all the time still
but that's not why we're here today
we're here today to celebrate a new
album yeah nightshade is out right now
yes
let's talk about this album in fact
we're going to get into some of the
lyrics we do the minimal and a maximal
so on this minimal here we're going to
talk about well we're going to talk
about the sound of simplicity i was just
thinking like when a few months ago when
we scheduled this what are we going to
talk to andrew bell about
but calm serenity what are the emotions
that are sort of evoked from his music
so we're going to talk about that on the
maximal we're going to talk about how
silence
is not
the absence of sound
but the absence of self
and so we're going to go deep on that so
congratulations on
the new album by the way that's another
amazing album man oh man thank you um i
know it's it's been out for about a
month now
chris and i were just talking about um
how quickly that that first month kind
of flew by and uh yeah i'm really proud
of this record it's
it's sort of um the third you know i
made this is the third record i made
with my uh
long time now producer chad copeland he
made black bear the record you were
talking about that was our first project
together we made my we made dive deep my
last record together and now we've made
knight chain it feels sort of like this
it's a little bit of an evolution in
sound but if you look at those three
records sonically like it's sort of a
little trilogy it is to be cliche about
it but um see that yeah yeah that's it
this record means a lot to me i'm really
proud of it thank you ours is a listener
driven show so i want to dive into some
questions here before we do that though
and we'll get into some more lyrics from
the album because i'm not going to ask
you what does this mean but i want to
talk about like what does this mean to
me and ryan when i hear the song cool
and also the album starts with this
devastating first line it's my favorite
first line now i have an obsession with
first lines my wife and i will go to
bookstores and we just we do dueling
first line so we'll just grab a random
book off the off the shelf and
we'll we'll compare the first line
really but then we started doing this
with albums
and your first line so you got the song
called swimmers which by the way every
single time i get into the car with my
daughter who's eight years old
every time we get in the car she'll say
can you play swimmers please every time
and so um you also have some some
eight-year-old fans as well she
absolutely loves it
the first line of the album is this
i don't think of you much anymore
now
there's a whole world
in that sentence right yeah i don't
think by the way how could you start an
album now
there's almost like this strange sort of
dishonesty or yearning like i don't want
to think of you much anymore but of
course i think of you if i'm starting
out a song or an entire album with this
yeah there's some irony there yes
what a beautiful devastating first line
that
did you know that was going to be the
first line of the album no uh in fact
that was probably the last song i wrote
for the record um and i actually i kind
of wanted
that i thought originally that was going
to be the last song on the album
to sort of tie the whole thing together
but as we were doing the sequencing and
um you know
songs kind of fall into place you know
you start getting really committed to
this particular song being track three
and this well this one's got to be track
seven and it just sort of happened where
i was like i want a strong song but
maybe not the most
um
maybe not the most impactful song you
don't you don't want to lead too you
know with your
what you consider to be the best song on
the record so
i don't know then all of a sudden i just
sort of had i kind of shifted my
mentality on that song and my
perspective on it and
all of a sudden i fell in love with the
idea of opening with that with that
track so
yeah it was it was kind of it was not on
purpose it was an accident well the
sequencing i think is another thing that
makes your albums what they are like
obviously these are cohesive projects
right ryan when when i listen to an
andrew bellum it's not a playlist it's
not a
it's not an uh a mixed c or a a mixtape
whatever it is it is it's a body of work
oh yeah and the intentionality is like
it really um it just shines man oh man
especially with like because it what is
it like four or five years in between
each album that you write yeah that's
incredible man four it's about four on
average typically and that's not like
it's not planned really it's just kind
of
typically out making out or i'll finish
an album and i'll tour it you know you
guys know about that like you write a
book you go out and you promote and tour
and then
you come home and you're exhausted by
that process and for me at least it's
hard for me to
want to just dive back into being
creative again chris and i were just
talking about this like i have to wear i
like wearing different hats for
different seasons um
when i finished making this nightshade
record i
shifted into okay how are we going to
release this record now and and um
and uh you know planning a tour and all
this stuff and and and now i've been
doing that for six months and and this
this weekend here in los angeles sort of
wraps up that season and then maybe i'll
shift into being creative again but all
of that ends up leaning or lending
itself toward um
a timeline where it ends up being about
three to three and a half years to four
years of making it to make a record and
uh
for me i know like the listeners i get a
lot of comments from people like make
you know can make records more often um
but uh
to me there's something kind of special
about each record of mine being sort of
this snapshot of a
you know a four-year period of my life
which is a pretty that's a long time
there's usually a lot of growth a lot of
changing that happens in those seasons
so i look back on each of my records as
like that's a season of my life and i'm
really proud of that to be honest so
yeah yeah no it's yeah it really yeah
the intentionality just really rings
through man thank you yeah we're gonna
dive into some of the lyrics and some of
those previous records as well on the
maximal but let's dive into some of
these questions right now emma we have a
question from jennifer on patreon
joshua has mentioned he has an echo in
his home due to mostly bare walls my
husband is a lot like him he does not
mind the echo although it isn't my
preference we compromise but there's
still an echo that disrupts my mood how
can some
how can some people be fine with echoes
in the home and others hate it
wow so so this is fascinating i i don't
know
there's a lot of assumptions in this
look you assume that i like echoes i
don't
like echoes at all right
but
an echo is not created by an emptiness
it's created by the noise in your home
so there's rarely ever an echo in my
home because it's really quiet
unless ella is running around yelling
and otherwise you know the echo is only
created by the noise the chaos that we
create
it's fascinating because you know i
don't hate artwork i don't hate things
on the wall obviously and we have a ton
of artwork here in the studio
and and we think that beauty is
essential
and so
i i think that this question the heart
of the question here is how can some
people be fine with echoes and other
people hate it it's almost like
preferences in music like some people
love reggae music
some people really dislike country music
whatever it is
it's all about a preference thing yeah
do you see this in your home
um
yeah so i when i when i heard that
question i actually thought of
my little studio space is um it's
located it's actually attached to our
bedroom my wife and his bedroom and um
it's it's larger than a closet it's not
a cli it has its own closet and a window
so it's but it's it's sort of this room
you can only get to through the bedroom
and that naturally became my studio
space but i i line the walls from floor
to ceiling um with these those little um
you know foam pad things you put in
recording studios to deaden the sound
and so when i go in that room it's like
dead silent it's actually eerily silent
you walk in you can feel almost
physically feel
the shift and the sonic
deadness for lack of better word that's
sort of like a you know a musician's
term but um
i love it in there it's so peaceful and
quiet my wife goes in there to do stuff
too
a lot too but uh
yeah i don't know i
that's that's that's the first thing i
thought of is that i have like the
opposite problem in my house it's
actually so quiet in there that i can
like
i have a little bit of um from all the
years of playing music and stuff i have
a little bit of tinnitus in my ears you
can hear that little so when i go in
there i can actually i can hear too much
yeah and it kind of freaks me out and i
have to
have to like turn something on turn some
some um
some music on or something to kind of
combat that yeah when i go in those
rooms i feel like i can hear my blood
pulsing through my veins yeah it's like
this i can like hear my heartbeat yeah
yeah it is a little eerie
we were recording in that temporary
studio space for a while and it was too
deadened i mean so we have when we first
got into this studio space
it was echoey in here only when we
talked though it's never echoey if
you're not making noise
and so we had to sound panel the whole
place and so i mean if you take a look
we have some beautiful sound panels in
here and it matches the paint and
aesthetically you can do something
that's beautiful that if you are
struggling with an echo
then i mean to me that echo is a sign of
oh maybe i don't have all the excess
anymore
but um you know it's kind of up to you
what is your individual preference yeah
i mean that's with any relationship
right whether it's a romantic
relationship or a friendship you gotta
you gotta respect each other's
preferences i'm wondering if jennifer
and her husband
can maybe uh
compromise uh uh or or recep respect
each other's preferences um equally so
you could have you know the living room
that's super echoey but maybe like
jennifer's got a little closet she can
go to and do some work with no echo
right uh but yeah i mean that's kind of
the balance of any relationship is is
trying to
uh just respect each other's preferences
what do you always say man uh what
relationships
bring misery how do you how do you say
that you know every relationship in your
life is going to make you miserable
right right but it's not actually the
relationship that makes you miserable
it's you that makes you miserable
exactly it's your expectation of these
other people anytime that we have
anxiety in our lives it's almost always
almost always relational in nature
but that anxiety always arises from us
because someone else can do something
in their life
it doesn't make the other person next to
them anxious at all but i have the
anxious or the discontented or the angry
feeling the upset feeling arise within
me yeah that has nothing to do with them
it has to do with my expectation
of
them
and so i think maybe if anything
jennifer
we can
raise our standards but lower our
expectations standards are like hey what
can we do around the house together
maybe hey if you both want something on
the walls but you don't want artwork on
the walls some great sound panels you
can get up that actually look
aesthetically pleasing totally yeah i
was gonna say the same thing i i love um
i mean you've got a good example of it
right here in the studio um there's
definitely ways to do that yeah yeah we
have a question here from
ashley in san francisco we are in the
summer season
and this is a time that many people take
a vacation
i'm just curious if you guys think that
if somebody is living a life that is
aligned with their values
if they should feel like they
need a vacation from their life
i'd be really curious to hear your
answer to this question and to also hear
you each expand a little bit
expand on a little bit about your
feelings towards how you viewed vacation
when you were working in the corporate
world and how you
view vacation now as minimalist so
ashley what's fascinating about this is
i think there are sort of two types of
vacations here one is a vacation where
you're trying to get away from something
the other is a vacation where it's
almost a pause or a a change in the
rhythm
now andrew i was thinking about this on
your new album you have a song on there
called shorthand which is sort of a
vacation in the middle of the album
totally in a way so can we talk about
that it's almost like this needed pause
yeah no that's a good way to describe it
um
each of my records uh this is the fourth
one now each one right somewhere in the
middle either track five or six
has a song that's a little bit of an
outlier relative to the rest of the
songs um
and the first time i did that it was
just sort of by accident you know i made
a song that was two and a half minutes
long didn't really it didn't really fit
the typical structure of a song
lyrically or there wasn't really a
chorus and then my second record there
happened to be another song that was
similar and then so then that kind of
became a thing that i like to do and um
there's something nice i mean this
actually on the fourth record it's a
full-on instrumental there's no vocal at
all and that was something i always
wanted to do um i like the idea of being
able to pause and be somebody else for a
minute on my recordings or even in live
performance it's it's kind of nice
to take a break from
uh you know not for any
not not because i don't like who i am or
being who i am or whatever i don't know
there's just something kind of
refreshing to me to like somewhere in
the middle just sort of like a palette
cleanser you know uh sonic
uh your ear cleanser uh for the for the
listener to be able to kind of reset and
then
start the the back side of the record
and that's that's very intentional yeah
and now you're sort of you're on tour
you're doing these different cities but
you're also i saw you're sort of
treating it like a vacation esque thing
right
it's i mean that's more of a mindset
than anything else because you can look
at it as a slog
or it's a oh my god i can't believe i
get to do this
yeah that's that's totally true that's a
that's a decision decision i have to
make every day is like last night we
were coming in to los angeles it's been
we had a long day we my manager chris
and i we we played golf all day in
nashville which was so fun but so
exhausting and went straight to the
airport and flew here and i'm like
so tired from the night before you know
we played a late show the night before
and and i was starting to get kind of
crabby like
i'm going to get no sleep tonight and i
got to run around town and then i got to
play the show my voice is tired and i
got all these press and people coming to
the show and i want to put on a good
show and and then i thankfully was able
to just sort of stop and be like
just chill out man like everything's
going great everything's going to be
great um you're so lucky to be able to
do this in the first place this is like
this has been the easiest tour by design
it's it's uh rather than taking on a big
huge production with us we just we're
just doing an acoustic tour
i have one instrument on my back um
everything has been so easy and and uh i
got to bring my wife with us to new york
city last weekend we had
an amazing time and um yeah so it's
definitely a choice to like shift your
mindset like to your point um and just
be grateful
yeah i feel away a lot on our tours it's
like yeah same exact thing the worst is
like you gotta show
you know uh at night you don't get back
to the hotel until ten i'm like an
extrovert so like i got all this energy
yeah after a show so when i go to bed
till midnight and then you gotta flight
at like 6 30 a.m and it's like oh wow
but yeah it is perspective i have to
stop sometimes look in the mirror and be
like dude you've got good problems these
are not bad problems to have but you
know to answer
um ashley's question head on
you know there's no right or wrong
answer to this
because what ashley is saying is like
hey if you're living with your values
then you're getting up every day and
every day is a gift and every day is a
vacation so do you need a vacation away
from your vacation
and that might be for some people but
still you know vacations are it is an
opportunity to pause it doesn't mean you
don't like your life it's maybe
something you can do to ex to get out
there and explore something new
um or maybe you are just working and
you're tired of working i mean you know
work is work yeah even though you know
all three of us here at this table love
what we do
there's work that has to be done that we
wish we didn't have to do you know i
hate paying taxes but guess what we have
to do that yeah and you might need a
break from that sometimes it's just
gonna feel you know
there's nothing wrong about that drew i
think that that one thing i think about
is with music even with a song like
the the music is music because of the
pauses between the notes or between the
lyrics or between the verses like
otherwise it's just noise
and so even if you live a life that you
feel is meaningful and enjoyable all the
time
if there isn't a rhythm to that
you can get burnt out yeah just like if
you're playing the same note over and
over there's this old like buddhist
parable about the the guy who found
actually i think it's like a sufi
parable but the the guy who found the
perfect note he's just playing in the
town square over and over and over and
people coming why don't you play the
songs used to play is like well no i
found the perfect note and so i'm just
strumming the same note over and over
and over
you kind of need a vacation from that
right yeah so if the vacation is running
towards something not running away from
something
that's when i find it to be useful yeah
for sure that made me think about how
with podcasts like we'll listen to it on
1.5 or sometimes 2.0 if you're josh you
can't do that with an album
oh yeah you can't you can't put it on
1.5 and just get through the album and
experience it
i really want to give you ranger bells
out but i only have 10 minutes right
exactly i'm going to put it on 2.0 and
listen to it real quick
yikes
well ashley let's send you a couple
tickets to our san francisco tour stop
the love people use things towards
coming to san francisco 20 cities total
across the u.s and canada we'll be there
in either january or february up in san
francisco we're going to be all over the
place um you could find a city nearest
you the minimalists.com tour if you're
listening to this or if you're ashley
we're gonna go ahead and send you a
couple tickets to that event ryan what
time is it you know what time it is it's
time for our lightning round where we
answer your text messages you can text
text your questions and comments to
six 937-202-4564 is that right is that
right no four six five four
nine three seven two oh two four six
five
four now andrew during the lightning
round this is where ryan and i and our
guests we do our best to answer
questions with a short shareable
less than 140 character response okay
but not really we just we monitor on a
bit and eventually podcast sean finds
something pithy and beautiful he tweezes
it out he puts it in the show notes so
people can copy and share our pithy
answers on social media if they'd like
and you can find all of our minimal
maxims in one place now
minimalmaxims.com
well emma looks like we've got a
question from paul
is there any evidence to suggest that
overconsumption of informative audio is
linked to anxiety i listen to podcasts
and audiobooks a lot and i'm wondering
if it is directly related to my anxiety
levels
i feel as though i don't provide myself
enough space to process my own thoughts
and i'm wondering if i should work in
more silence
wow wow so um
andrew had a podcast called stemma for a
while which i really enjoy oh man i just
i like the way you edited it and it was
never about you it was your podcast but
it was always about
someone else you took yourself it was a
rather egoless podcast but it was it was
exploring people through their memories
of food
it was fascinating i think if ryan and i
did one of those it'd just be like well
government cheese and you know whatever
food we could buy food stamps generic
pop-tarts but that's a memory yeah that
defines like who you you know who you
became in some way yeah and i like what
ryan was saying earlier about the
um
well listening to things at two times
the speed or i need to consume more
that's where that comes from quite often
i need to hurry through this i need to
get
through this
of course that's going to cause some
anxiety right and music i found i have
transitioned away from music and i
listen to more podcasts than music now
and part of that's unfortunate in fact i
found myself going back more
to music i'll throw on pandora because
i'm still the guy who has pandora we
have some gin sears in the room they
don't really know what pandora is but
i'll just throw on the andrew bell
pandora station and then it'll rock for
a few hours in in the morning we're just
drinking coffee reading and
it's calming
and
and so
if i were to throw a podcast on in the
background i think that would start to
stress me out a bit yeah but yeah i mean
i think music quite often creates the
the the soundscape force you don't have
to pay attention to it it can be on in
the background do you find this as well
do you are you listening more to
podcasts these days
um i go in seasons with that um when i'm
making a record usually i'm listening to
so much of my own music that when i'm
not in the studio i kind of just need an
ear break um
or at least maybe not listening to pod
or to like pop music um you know like
i'll get in the car and i'll just put on
you know the sirius xm real jazz station
just something really like easy
listening you know that's not just
overtly
pop music um all the time but no i i
have found that i can actually kind of
relate to this question um there's some
kind of little twinge of anxiety that i
get where it's like i'm constantly
having to consume something music or a
podcast or something and even just even
having the phone in my pocket sometimes
i don't know what there is about that
energy sometimes that i'm just like if i
just put it on the counter and leave the
room and go water the plants without
having to listen to something i there's
something really i've lately
particularly that i found refreshing
about that just not having to always be
consuming something yes
and so that's definitely something i've
been trying to pursue more because i
feel more refreshed
at times without it part of this is
we've been told so often that we're
consumers in fact businesses call us
that right our consumers you know the
people who consume our product and
that's true we all need to consume some
stuff we wrote about this and a lot of
people use things but i think we've let
our creative muscles atrophy so much as
a society because it is so easy to
consume now right it's it's one click
purchases it's on demand streaming it's
every album i could ever want in my
pocket
and
it makes it so much easier and more
difficult simultaneously right because
it's easier to have access to everything
but now it's difficult because we're so
overwhelmed we're so overloaded with
excess we have we have too much of a
good thing it's the fire hose of of
pleasure seeking
and it's all right there in our pocket i
love the thing about putting the phone
away i often my wife and i will put our
phones in our junk drawer which is a
great metaphor yeah and then we just
walk around the block we did it this
morning we get up in the morning we'll
have make a cup of coffee and instead of
you know listening to a podcast and
walking around the block hey just gonna
walk around the block together yeah and
it's
it's silence but not in the the truest
sense it's not the absence of sound it's
calm
and and there's nothing else feeding
into the to the chaos the hard part i
found though is that we live our
cultures just like become such a um
we use these phones for so many
different things they take pictures
you know um
messaging and we've become so reliant on
these things where
you know um if you weren't available to
receive a text message
maybe 20 years ago if you didn't get a
phone call that was sort of
understandable
but now it's like well you didn't see my
text and now everything's everything's
ruined because you know you were late or
you didn't know that we changed the the
location of the meeting or whatever fill
in the blank
that's the hard part i found about it
it's not as easy just to walk away from
your phone anymore because of what we've
turned these things into culturally yeah
it's interesting so yeah technology in a
way has really changed the expectations
of society yeah which yeah that's
technology should not dictate our
expectations you can tweet that podcast
on here's my pithy answer though for uh
paul uh too much is always too much
so
so look paul if you feel like it's too
much then it is and you've got to take a
pause if you were to have like one
little slice of apple pie or strawberry
rhubarb my favorite pie it's great but
if you eat the whole pie it's too much
and you're gonna feel bad afterwards
yeah and just like andrew was saying
it's like he needs a break he's gotta go
out uh
clear his his ear palate
and uh have some silence and he's able
to recognize that so paul it sounds like
you are recognizing this and that's
great so yeah take a little break here's
my pithy answer for you
peace cannot be created
it is already there beneath the chaos
so
we go seeking peace right we're
searching for peace we try to purchase
peace right if i buy the right app
or the right yoga mat
if i buy the right thing if i consume
the right goods or the right podcast
that's going to bring me peace it's
never going to bring you peace the peace
is already there and it can only be
uncovered
and the only way we can really uncover
it is identify what is the too much what
is that chaos
because what's enough for me might be
too much for ryan or what is too much
for ryan might be too little for me with
uh with respect to a particular
item or routine or app or song or
podcast whatever it is
and so it's so highly individual that
it's perspectival and i think that
we go searching for peace
not realizing oh my gosh it's already
here
right now
this is where the piece is i'm not going
to find it out there i'm not going to
find it through the next acquisition
yeah yeah you cannot consume your way to
peace ooh tweet that podcast sean
well we got so much more to talk about
ryan but you got something for us first
yeah man here are some voicemail
comments and insights from our listeners
check them out hi my name is karen and
i'm calling from philadelphia i'm
calling in response to the impulses
episode and i had a comment for erica
who has the business that may or may not
um align with her minimalist values now
i just had a thought about that because
i sew and i do a lot of sewing for a
living so i've always had a large stash
of fabrics
i also
have a side retail business
that causes me to sell things to people
and i don't always feel comfortable
about their purchases
it sounds like her business is some sort
of a craft or yarn store
and i thought it might be
a good way to at least partially
transition
to start doing events either at the
store or at another location put up a
sign to where customers hey is your yarn
stash getting overwhelming come join me
and
your other customers and knit for a good
cause make something for the homeless
make things to donate to refugees
do something that will use up some of
that stash
make people feel good about what they're
doing with it and also get together as a
community it might be a way to spread
some minimalist values while she's
hosting but it would also do a lot of
good in the short and long term
hi my name is cody from oahe nevada i'm
responding to episode 46 called let go
you were talking about social media and
particularly scrolling through facebook
how it's how it brings discontent and is
essentially a waste of time my solution
to that is that i have unfollowed all of
my quote friends and groups this makes
my news feed completely empty and clean
and keeps me from scrolling mindlessly
to see what people are up to
some people might think of this as being
a bit extreme but i find that it allows
me to be more deliberate in my use of
facebook if i'm thinking about someone
in particular i can go directly to their
profile and see what they are up to or i
can send them a message and actually
talk with them
another thing i do to minimize facebook
is that i try to keep my friends list
below 150 people
studies have shown that the human mind
cannot keep track of more than 150
relationships
if you have more than 150 chances are
there are people on your list that you
don't know or remember
either way they are probably not adding
value to your life and are not worth
cluttering up your social media
all right y'all big thanks to andrew
bell for joining us today check out his
new album it's called nightshade we have
a bunch more surprise questions
for andrew this thursday on patreon
that's the maximal episode on the
minimalist private podcast you can just
go on over to patreon.com
the minimalists to listen to that but
first real quick for right here right
now here's one thing that's going on in
the life of the minimalists ryan a brand
new month is approaching yeah man we
have a free minimalism calendar it's the
minimalism game calendar you can
download from our resources page over on
our website
theminimalists.com
resources you get that calendar for free
you can print it out and you can play
the 30-day minimalism game with a friend
a loved one
or a mortal enemy
[Music]
mariah and i are going to play this next
month ah so your mortal enemy exactly
to the death
oh man um yeah i don't know what the i
don't know what the prize is gonna be
we'll figure it out or maybe we'll just
play together we'll just like i don't
think we can talk about the prize on
this podcast
we'll have to save that for patreon
all right listen
thankfully sean bleeped that
for our added value segment this week
it's not that
um
real mature just oh you know what andrew
bell my favorite song from the album is
called inside voices and we're gonna
dive deep into
just the thought of our inside voices
the voices in our head our thoughts that
ruminate out of control
let's finish this episode with
inside voices from andrew bell's new
album nightshade by the way we have a
bunch more surprise questions this week
like how does minimalism play a role in
making music more meaningful do specific
genres of music have a greater effect on
the mind after a lifetime in the city i
moved to a rural area can this bring me
peace plus a million more questions for
andrew bell and the minimalists and if
you want to hear all that join us on the
minimalist private podcast this week
visit patreon.com the minimalist to
subscribe and get your personal link so
our private podcast plays in your
favorite podcast app
you can follow the minimalists on
facebook twitter and instagram at the
minimalists come to one of our live
podcast shows visit theminimalist.com
tour to find a city near you
if you have a question comment or
minimalism tip for our podcast email a
voice memo to podcast the minimalist dot
com
comment on this episode at youtube.com
slash the minimalists and if you want
our show notes in your inbox sign up for
our email list at theminimals.com you'll
also receive our simple sunday
newsletter for free ladies and gentlemen
emma the immigrant yeah
all right y'all if you leave here today
with just one message let it be this
love people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all we'll see you next
time
[Music]
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'll be fine
without it